[Music]
good afternoon friends welcome to I'd
like to know which is our Bible question
and answer program have you ever had a
special toy that you really like when I
was growing up I had a little truck I
even gave it a name was called Blake and
I played with that truck so much that
the wheels fell off one time and the
axle fell off and the door opened up and
fell off and it just I just had to junk
it because I just play with it too much
well this this program is is like is
like my Blake truck the only good thing
is that um we can't play with it too
much we can never play with this program
too much because we love it so much
because it gives us a chance to answer
your questions to study the word of God
to meet together we do have fun on the
set and I want to assure you the rumors
are true we do love each other in Jesus
Christ amen and we have a good time
working together here at Secrets
unsealed and some TV my name is CA
Murray and I'm in the company of Pastor
Steven bore and Pastor David Salazar and
uh you are with us and that makes
everything just so perfect and complete
amen we like to get your questions we we
we are solicitous of getting your
questions and should you like to join in
on the fun we encourage you to do so by
writing to us at TV atoms
mv.org and we will get to your questions
just as soon as we can we have a great
announcement because uh the stack used
to be fairly large gentlemen but we're
working our way through the stacks not
quite as as long as it once were once
was so you will get to hear your
questions much quicker because we are
scurrying through trying to answer them
without being too fast giving you due
diligence as you take the time to write
them we want to take the time to answer
them so we're not necessarily dealing
dealing with speed we want quality
answers from the word of God and we make
you that promise that each and every
answer will come from the word of God
Pastor Steph boy if you would ask God's
blessing upon this program we will begin
sure our father and our God what a
privilege it is to live in a country
where we can freely open the book study
it assimilate it and share it father we
thank you for this program where we can
take the questions and do the research
and through your Holy Spirit give
answers that are satisfactory to those
who watch the
program we plead for your presence in
this program today amen give us Divine
wisdom from on high and bless those who
are watching the program that the
program might be a blessing to them as
well we thank you Father for the
privilege of Prayer
and thank you because you have answered
this prayer because we come in the
powerful name of Jesus amen amen and
amen this question comes to us from Dan
danat d a n g k a t uh is what I have
before me and it concerns the 2300
years I have a question about the 2300
years I have been reading and I noticed
that some people
disagree with this 20 300y year prophecy
arriving at
1844 as they think a day is nowhere
found in the Bible that a day is a year
is this because this person is a predus
SL
futurist a comment I read that without
the 2300 year prophecy arriving in at
1844 the SDA movement will crash and
nothing more in what way could this be
true
my other question is how do we get from
BC to
ad
okay you go through zero but I don't
want to be flipping let's first
establish the text that tell us uh a
year a day um I will will give you your
flowers uh because I have the the work
you you have excellent study 20 reasons
why the Year Day principle is applicable
and uh can that be download
it can be downloaded for free from our
website okay because I have the print
out I have the the hard copy but it's
good to know that you can get that so
you can fortify Yourself by going to
Pastor B's study notes and and
downloading those okay let's go to
Ezekiel and to numbers and just
establish the the text in the in the
word of God
Amen so uh we can go I guess I first we
I'll go to Ezekiel okay and um the verse
there if Ezekiel 4:6
it reads and when thou Hast accom
accomplished them lie again on thy right
side and thou shalt bear the iniquity of
the house of Judah 40 days I have
appointed thee each day for a year so
here we have one of the texts that are
very it's very clear direct that in in
Prophecy speaking of Ezekiel the prophet
he was to lay for 40 days that would
mean 40 years for the Israelites so
that's one of the verses and then we
have numbers I think you're going to
numbers Pastor I am there numbers
1434 or according to the number of days
in which you spied out the land 40 Days
for each day you shall bear your guilt
one year namely 40 years and you shall
know that I you shall know my rejection
uh that is numbers
1434 now pastor bore um I put to you
this question so we know the principle
does
exist is this a principle that we apply
throughout the Bible whenever we see
numbers when I say numbers not the book
of numbers but whatever we see numbers
mentioned or Are there specific times
and specific places where this principle
works and specific times when it does
not
work only when we're dealing with
symbolic
prophecy uh let's take an example uh
Daniel 7:25
MH this is a prophetic
passage and uh it's dealing in
symbols and when you're dealing with
symbols the symbols are to be taken just
like that
symbolic uh so it says here in Daniel
chter 7 and verse 25 somebody want to
read that it says and he shall speak
great words against the most high and
shall wear out the Saints of the most
high and think to change times and laws
and they shall be given into his hand
andto a time and times and the dividing
of
Time how many of you have ever seen a
horn that
speaks it's a little horn that's
speaking no one no
one um okay that's one thing how many of
you have ever ever seen a dragon Beast
that has seven heads and 10 horns never
seen one just how how many of you have
ever seen a lion that represent a lion
that represents a kingdom a bear that
represents a kingdom Daniel 7 is dealing
with symbols right yeah that represent
something far
greater now the interesting thing is
that uh Why didn't it say in Daniel 7:25
three and a half
years why does it say time times and the
dividing of time this the uh expression
is
unusual because it's symbolic right and
it appears in a chapter where everything
is symbolic true so the time period must
also be symbolic yeah you can't pull out
of the sequence in the middle of the in
the middle of you it's like trying to
change the field in the middle of the
game yeah you're you're in a symbolic so
everything has to be symbolic and so so
let's say for example that I'm going to
take a three and a half year trip to
Colombia MH and in my farewell I say
I'll see you in time times and the they
writing of time you think that guy's
crazy or or I say see you in 42 months
mhm or see you in one , 260 days the
expression has a symbolic flavor yes MH
and it appears in the midst of symbols
so the time period has to be symbolic as
well and that's when you apply the
principle because the symbolic or is a
prophecy symbolic prophecy time you need
to apply the principle of time a day for
a year rather than just take it as a as
also being only a symbolic time but it
actually does give you the time frame so
that you can actually understand how
long it was to last there was a specific
time but it was a symbolic time is not
literal as to be taken literally and you
know it's really interesting that
conservative
Christians believe that the 70 weeks are
years they have to apply the Year Day
principle to that prophecy that the 70
weeks are 490 years they're applying the
Year Day principle MH but that's the
first part of the 2300 days yes
so why do they take the first part of
the 2300 days as being symbolic days and
then they say but the rest are literal
days it doesn't make any sense
whatsoever yeah you have to stay
consistent and it's only that
consistency that keeps you from going
off the rails uh once you you step into
Pro prophecy and and and the prophetic
mindset you've got to stay with that and
uh given the fact also that the Bible
will tell you when it's appropriate to
make that application you know if you
let the Bible be its own interpreter it
will tell you when to apply the Year Day
principle yeah and pedist and
futurists they take these periods as
being literal uh the predus believe that
the three and a half uh years actually
were the times that Antiochus epiphanies
a guy in 165 BC desecrated the Jewish
temple sacrificed a pig on the altar uh
and persecuted the Jews so I said n that
uh prophecy of Daniel 7:25 oh that was
fulfilled in the distant future doesn't
have anything to do with the papacy and
futurists they say ah that doesn't apply
to us today that's after the Rapture so
what the what Satan has done he's
projected this period to the distant
past or to the Future so that people
don't see the Fulfillment of Prophecy
right before their eyes yes yes and this
is the thing you know when you study the
scriptures and the prophecy
uh the light of Daniel Revelation how
the Lord revealed this information in
the end of time we can truly understand
that this prophecies were given so that
we might know the time in which we live
and the time of the end when will the
final part of God's you know the
Redemption plan will take place when the
conflict will finish and what is going
to be established right before he's
coming which is the deception by the by
the papacy really through the power of
the enemy and the uh mainstream
Christianity who have forsaken the
prophecies and the Bible to establish
themselves in in in a way to mislead and
to deceive the world so um you know this
the question that mentioned in 2300 days
prophecy you know why do we arrive to
1844 if we study the scriptures and we
study the prophecy of Daniel 8 I mean
789 925 where it speaks of the command
to restore Jerusalem and we understand
and we can clearly see that that's the
beginning of the nine I mean 2300 year
prophecy and that was in the year of uh
457 BC we can truly 457 BC right am I
correct yes you are correct yes and we
take it all the way through the the end
of those 2300 days which is years into
1844 the the Autumn of 18 year 44 so you
know it's it's sad that the individuals
who question don't really give the Bible
enough of a opportunity to interpret
itself and to study with an open mind
and see what the Bible reveals the more
study this is one of the things that I'm
very pleased and proud of my church
uh the sanctuary message and this is
part of that overall Sanctuary message
yeah the 2300 days gives us an
orientation as to where we are in time
as to what is happening in history and
and the only real Protestant
denomination that has wrestled with this
and come out with a theology based on it
is the seven Adventist Church nobody is
looking at the world in terms of the
sanctuary and the day of atonement and
what happened during the day of
atonement and what happened at the end
of the day of atonement uh we are the
only ones who have wrestled with that so
we know what's going on on Earth we also
know what's going on in heaven and we
also have uh an understanding as to when
it's going to end now we we don't know
the day we don't know the hour but we
know it is near and that's why the
Adventist Church Is So eschatologically
based because we work from the end back
as it were we know that the end is
coming so how ought you to live and
behave and conduct yourself given the
fact that we don't have a lot of time
and that's what this Doctrine does for
ush somebody once asked me well if you
believe that time periods are symbolic
and you apply the Year Day principle why
do you say that the Thousand Years of
Revelation chapter 20 are literal
literal years why don't you apply the
the Year Day principle to that and my
answer has always been because the Bible
itself applies the Year Day principle
and then I read uh from Isaiah
24 uh where it's talking about the
Millennium it says it shall come to pass
in that day that the Lord will punish on
high the host of the exalted ones those
are the Angels mhh uh the fallen angels
and the earth and the kings of the Earth
Earth those are are the Wicked on Earth
uh they will be gathered together as
prisoners are gathered in the pit and
will be shut up in the prison that's
what happens with the devil his angels
and the wicked and then it says and will
be shut up uh in many after many days
they will be
punished so it says many days yes but
how does revelation interpret the many
days a millennium A Thousand Years
thousand years so so when you compare
Isaiah and Revelation the days in Isaiah
are years in Revelation 20 so you do
apply the Year Day principle amen amen
now you know the question this you know
young individual has is in regards to
that there's a comment he read that
without the 2200 days prophecy or year
prophecy arriving to 1844 the SDA
movement will crash and nothing
more um you
know the Bible or the well the spirit
prophecy y has given us a lot of
understanding and the Bible gives a
understanding of the prophecies but the
Adventist Church is not does not has a
foundation in just one thing it's not
like we're founded on only the 2300 day
prophecy uh it it really I think it's
it's a diservice to say that the ADV
church is is based on that only um we
are a prophetic movement and the
prophecy help us understand what you
know how the church came about in this
as far as organizing itself realizing
that it was a time when the knowledge of
the lord of the law of God of everything
that is given in the Bible was to be
given and and with that said the the the
Adventist Church has an identity very
very con connected linked to the
sanctuary to the to this judgment to the
tr day prophecy but it's not the only
thing that defines or proves that the
church is God's church so um I I would
say that that comment of somebody saying
that without that that church would have
no way to stand it's it's really
misunderstanding why there is many
foundations or many pillars of her faith
not just this one I think it is looking
at it sort of upside down prophecy is as
old as God
himself we didn't invent prophecy it was
there these truths are in the word we
just discovered them it's like finding
they said Columbus discovered America no
America was here you know you just Happ
to sail across and you hit it um
the truths were there in the word always
have been there a group of people began
to study and they found out what was
already there so the aen church was
never in danger of crashing because the
truths preceded the aist church they
were always there we just studied and
studied and studied until we Unearthed
those truths but the truths were already
there you know the foundational
prophecy that proves Beyond any doubt
that this is God's Remnant church is
revelation 10 mhm and the comments that
Ellen White makes about the Advent
movement 1844 the Fulfillment of
Prophecy you know if we if that was
false uh we would have to discard illen
white and we would have to discard
Revelation 10 which is the clearest
Prophecy of the origin of the Adventist
movement uh in the whole Bible right and
so uh you know it is crucially important
that we understand the 2300 days the way
that uh the sth Day Adventist Church
understands it and we have a solid
foundation to do it however it's true
that the Seventh Day Adventist Church
believes that the dead are dead it
believes that the Sabbath is the day
that we're supposed to keep yes it
believes in healthful living but all of
those doctrines actually came forth from
entering the most holy place in
1844 you know pretty soon uh you know
they said oh well the the law is in
heaven because the Earth was was a
reflection so the Ten Commandments must
be up there they must be still binding
and oh the Sabbath is in the center of
the ten commandments so so and the and
the Ten Commandments are in heaven so
the Sabbath must still be binding and
the pot of Mana teaches helpful living
among among other things too and uh you
know if a person if a person doesn't
goes to heaven or to hell at the moment
of death why would there be a judgment
beginning 1844
and so all of the doctrines of the
church hinge On Believing what happened
in
1844 uh I believe that there could be a
Seventh Day Adventist Church with all of
this collection of doctrines but that
what happened in 1844 is so foundational
to what we are as a
church and the work of Christ in these
end times that's why when when you study
the the the link the chain link of
doctrines and doctrinal premises U
there's there's
no break in the chain there are no holes
in in our do Foundation it's solid and
one Builds on and feeds into the other
so there's no way that the movement
could crash and burn because as I said
the doctrines have always been there uh
just God called out a people who studied
who studied and who studied and they
made some uh some some missteps but they
corrected those missteps and Contin to
study and God rewarded their study with
a doctrinal premise that we can stand on
that we can be proud of but more than
that that lets us know what's happening
in heaven what's happening on Earth and
how soon we are to the coming of our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ by the way
the Seventh Day Adventist Church has
never established a date for the coming
of Christ MH not once because in 1844
there was no Adventist Church and that's
actually a good
point about 19 years it's interesting
that no you're right it's a good very
good point because the actual movement
that established or went over this
Prophecy of the 2300 year prophecy was
the millerite movement which was not an
Adventist movement it was not the 7
Adventist movement it was an Adventist
movement in the sense that they were
expecting the coming of Christ but it
was not the SDA 7 Adventist Church
organized they were not even EX in
existence then so the Lord show showed a
man William Miller the understanding of
Prophecy of Daniel he he did such a
method of understanding and study that
he came to this Revelations of the Lord
and God directed him to point people to
the time when they expected Christ to
come but it was truly a misunderstanding
of of what the event was not the date
but the event and ultimately God gave
even though they went through the
experience of bit disappointment the
lord gave them gave the the the the
people that were following the movement
or following the Lord and they were part
of the that movement they received the
light to understand what really was or
what happened that date and so as you
well mentioned the the establishment of
the SDA church and the
more understanding of doctrines of other
doctrines hinged on this movement that
was a prophetic movement that really
understood the concept of Prophecy
applied to the themselves to the
understanding of what it meant and we're
trying to live a life that will bring
bring them closer to the Lord and the
Lord then revealed to them the truth of
the Sabbath the truths well first the
truth of that he was it was a judgment
of God that started the inter you know
basically a judgment then then the
understanding of the sanctuary the
Sabbath and everything else that came
along with that so you know but God has
given us the light and we are so
thankful for that amen so let's deal
with the BC and AD thing yes yes BC and
AD the person says my other question is
how do I get from BC to ad well you
would have to live in the times of
Christ I was looking at that you have to
have a long time um how do I get from BC
to ad I'm not
sure I'm assuming the regardless to this
question I I think that I sort of
answered by saying in Daniel
9:25 uh you know when it talks about
when the 2300 days started that's the
only thing that makes to me sense relate
to what she's mentioning uh or he's
mentioning J
so I'm I thinking that it's um you know
when it started and how you get from
there to to ad but uh or maybe he's
talking about the the the year the fact
that you jump from 1 BC to 1 a you don't
count the number one twice you only
count it once I don't know it's it's
hard to tell uh specifically what the is
because you don't
go 32 1 0123
you don't you don't go through the year
zero you only have one one time so if
you're doing your numbers you got to
compensate for that when you're Crossing
from BC to ad um that's the only thing I
I could think of because that's a
general mistake that people make they
count years like you count numbers and
you you can't do that yeah they count
the number one twice they count the
number one twice and there's actually
only one year between 1 BC and 1 a
correct it jumps from one to one one to
one not two years because you go from
one to zero 0 to one that's two years
and that's where the millerites made
their their first mistake in saying that
Christ was going to come in
1843 yeah yeah that's the thing but I
think that for for our friend the best
thing would be to get a study guide on
this prophecy I think we have a stud
guide Pastor board that you have made
and uh the best way for it is to to go
over the evidence from the Bible per
prophecy that really clears this out for
them one of the things that is it's so
exciting working at this minist you
don't have to invent the wheel if it's
in the
Bible uh Pastor Bor has probably got
something written on it some place you
can download it you can download it and
have it and it does help your study it
it helps make you wise to Salvation to
have the material right there in front
of you amen uh the age of the internet
is a wonderful thing and we have taken
full advantage of it well again our time
has fast slipped into eternity allow me
in closing to wish you both Grace and
peace through our Lord and savior Jesus
Christ we'll see you again soon bye-bye
and God bless
[Music]